keep in mind it's not just the police
it's the military hundreds of navy seals
the estimate is could soon lose their
job thousands throughout the other
services marine corps air force army
navy
can we afford that at the state level
this is particularly painful entire
counties in the state of maine for
example will lose paramedic services
tonight because of a vaccine mandate it
takes effect at midnight
what does this mean for people who live
in the state of maine lisa kaim is a
state senator from the state and we're
happy to have her on tonight senator
thanks so much for coming on give us a
sense of what this will mean for people
in the state of maine
thank you tucker yes
tonight as you said at midnight ems
workers will no longer be answering
calls and we don't know on the state
level how many have have been let go but
there will be 911 calls that go
unanswered in the state of maine and the
difference here in maine that's um
that's good to understand is that we
have already done away with all
philosophical and religious exemptions
and it is very difficult to get a
medical exemption at all so these ems
workers they are faced with the choice
of feeding their family or taking the
vaccine and
we i have talked to many people
throughout the state there are
definitely dire consequences coming and
we are not sure yet what the impact
overall is going to be
if your 911 call goes unanswered what's
the point of having a government at that
honestly like what's the point and why
isn't there a revolt against this
there absolutely
there's going to be a lot of people that
are going to be hurt by this but at the
at this moment no one knows this really
has
not been well reported the people that
are living in communities where the
entire ems service or or possibly uh you
know 50 percent or a large percentage
are no longer to be working those
communities don't yet know this is
something that we are going to find out
as it unfolds over the next week so
people who
suffer heart failure or have a stroke
and call for an ambulance and it doesn't
come some of those people will die as a
result of this
that's the most dire consequence of all
and that is one of the major concerns
that that we have i spoke with an ems
the director of maine ems today
and
they have some preliminary numbers but
they won't know until sunday night how
many workers are actually going to be
getting done so at this point
it's very strongly like mismanagement to
assume that the vaccine mandate is going
to work for these people who are
actually the most careful of anyone in
our society they understand
the transmission and they're careful of
their patients and now we're we're
kicking them out and saying your
services are no longer needed the main
people don't know
right so politicians know more than
health care workers about medicine and
everyone acts like that's normal but
it's not normal and it's also untrue i
appreciate senator kaim you're coming on
tonight thank you